الحكايه واقعيه هاد القصه هادي بدات واحد
النهار كنت جالس معندي ما يدار دخلت
اليوتيوب كنتفرج في المحتوى اللي كيعجبني
واحد النهار طلع لي واحد الفيديو هاد
الفيديو هذا اشهار ديال واحد اللعبه هاد
اللعبه هادي قمت بتحميل ديالها
وبديت كنلعب فيها اول مرحله ديال اللعبه
هي انشاء ديال الشخصيه في هذه المرحله
هادي
عليا نختار الجنس ديال الشخصيه الحجم
ديالها اللون ديالها شكل ديال الشعر
ديالها العينين ديالها الى اخره
الشخصيه ديالي وقمت بانشاء ديالها دزت
المرحله الثانيه هذه المرحله هادي كنتعلم
فيها واحد المجموعه من المهارات الاساسيه
باش ممكن انني نلعب اللعبه دونك تعلمت
هادوك المهارات بديت اللعبه ديالي
كنجز واحد المجموعه ديال المهام اللي هي
اساسيه هاد المهام هذه هي مهام سهله ولكن
مكنتني انني نتعلم كيفاش انني العب
بالشخصيه ديالي كيفاش انني نتحرك داخل
اللعبه كيفاش انني نهز نهز دوك المهام
البسيطه
ديال المهام
تعطوني مهام اخرى هاد المهام هذه كان
مطلوب مني اني نديرها ولكن ما معطينيش
الطريقه اولا الترتيب ديالها كيفاش اني
نديرها دونك هنايا كان عليا انني نختار
شنو هما المهام اللي غادي نبدا بهم اخترت
المهام اللي غادي ندير درتهم كاملين
ودزت المرحله
المواليه هذه المرحله هادي كنكتشف فيها ان
اللعبه مازال ما بداتش ان هذاك الجزء
الاول كامل كانت هي مقدمه اللعبه
الجزء الثاني من اللعبه اكتشف ان خاصني
ندير واحد الاختيار واحد الاختيار هذا
كيحدد الموقع اللي غانبدا به اللعبه ديالي
اشمن مدينه غنبدا بها واش غنبدا بالصحراء
اولا في الجبال او لا في الغابات وكل
منطقه من هذه المناطق عندها خصائص ديالها
درت الاختيار ديالي من بعد كنطلع في واحد
المدينه في هذه المدينه هذه اكتشف ان كاين
واحد المجموعه ديال البيانات البنايات
كاين واحد المجموعه ديال الشخصيات كل
شخصيه عندها واحد المجموعه ديال الخصائص
كاين واحد المجموعه ديال اللاعبين الاخرين
دونك هنا
واحد الشخصيه وشرحت لي ان هاد اللعبه هادي
هي لعبه ديال العالم مفتوح وهي لعبه ما
فيهاش مهام وانا الشخصيه ديالي ماشي شخصيه
الرئيسيه ان الشخصيه ديالي هي بحال كاع
الشخصيات وان هاد الشخصيه ديالي
ممكن انها دير المهام اللي بغات وممكن
انني ما ندير حتى شي حاجه في اللعبه
واللعبه كتبقى خدامه
دونك بالنسبه للعبه
نقدر نختار فيها شنو بغيت نكون ممكن انني
نكون التاجر ممكن انني نكون مضارب يعني
نشري واحد المجموعه ديال المنتجات ونعاود
البيع ديالهم ممكن انني ندير تنقيب على
الذهب ممكن انني مزرعه ديالي ونربي فيها
الحيوانات ممكن انني نمشي نقوم بواحد
المجموعه المهام الاشخاص اخرين لاعبين
اخرين اللي كاينين في اللعبه دونك هنا
ولاو عندي بزاف ديال الاختيارات
والامكانيه ديال اللاعب ولات مفتوحه
بعد ما اختاريت شنو الحوايج اللي غادي
ندير في اللعبه بديت كندير المهام
اللي كتعجبني درت المهمه الاولى المهمه
الثانيه المهمه الثالثه وكان علي انني
نحدد الاولويات ديالي من الاول حتى الاخر
واحد الوقيته
اكتشفت ان ولاو عندي مهارات جديده في
اللعبه اكتشف انني بنيت واحد المجموعه
ديال القدرات
منين وصلت لهذه المرحله هادي
دزت المرحله المواليه ولقيت ان بديت كان
واجه واحد المجموعه ديال الصعوبات هاد
الصعوبات هادو خلاوني انني نعرف ان كاين
واحد الحدود اللي ما يمكنش انني نتجاوزها
هنا بديت كنحاول انني نلقى طريقه الطريقه
الوحيده اللي لقيت هو انني خاصني نتواصلو
واحد المجموعه ديال اللاعبين اخرين هاد
اللاعبين اخرين هما اللي غيمكنوني انني
نتجاوز هذيك المرحله وندوس المراحل اللي
هي متقدمه من اللعبه دونك شنو الاختيار
اللي كان عندي هو انني نقدر
نتواصل مع هاد الناس باش نتعاون معهم باش
تلقى الحل اللي كنقلب عليه دونك باش
نتواصل مع هاد الناس بالضروره انني نربط
معهم واحد المجموعه ديال العلاقات انني
نشوف شنو هما الحوايج اللي مشتركين
بيناتنا شنو هما الاولويات ديال كل واحد
فينا وهنا انضميت لواحد المجموعه هذه
المجموعه هادي كانت كتكون مجموعه ديال
الاشخاص بفئات عمريه مختلفه من اجناس
مختلفه من دول وقارات مختلفه
شنو الحاجه اللي كانت كتجمع بيناتنا اول
حاجه هي حب اللعبه
كنستمتعوا بها وثاني حاجه هو اننا بغينا
نطوروا من الشخصيات اللي كنلعبوا بها وانا
نتجاوزو هادوك المراحل المتقدمه دونك منين
وصلنا لهاد المرحله هادي
كان خاصنا اننا نتواصلوا باش نتواصلوا
بيناتنا دونك
خاصنا واحد المنصه هاد المنصه هادي كانت
منصه ديسكورد
عندنا واحد المجموعه ديال الرومات اللي
ممكن انك تدخل لهم وممكن انك تهضر فيهم مع
لاعبين اخرين بالاوديو
التواصل كنا كنديروا واحد المجموعات
المجموعات هادو كنقوموا بمجموعه ديال
المهام مجموعين
الاشكال اللي كان مطروح هو شكون اللي غادي
نجز هاد المهمه وشكون اللي غادي يلعب هذا
الدور دونك هنا كان علينا اختيار ديال
الادوار ديالنا كان علينا الاختيار ديال
واحد القائد
اللي غادي يعطي لكل شخص من الاشخاص المهمه
ديالو وشنو هما الحوايج اللي غادي نبداو
بهم شنو هما الحوايج اللي ما خاصناش
نديرهم الى اخره دونك هنا كان علينا اننا
مع بعضياتنا واننا نتعرفوا على بعضياتنا
واننا
واحد
العلاقه داخل اللعبه
من بعد هذه المرحله هادي
لاحظنا ان كاين عندنا واحد الفريق بدا
يتكون ولات عندنا واحد المجموعه ديال
العلاقات اللي تكونت اللي تطورات خارج
اللعبه
بعد مده طويله داخل لعبه
اكتشفت ان كاين في اللعبه حروب يعني اش
يعني الدول كتحارب في هذه الحروب هادي
كيكون عندنا 300 شخص ضد 300 شخص وهنا اول
مره كنكتشف واحد الحاجه هو ان
كاين واحد القائد اللي كيقول عشرين رئيس
ديال المجموعه وكل مجموعه كيكون فيها 15
لاعب
هادوك العشرين قائد
اللي مع القائد ديال المجموعه كامله كيعطي
الاوامر ديالو
وهذوك العشرين فينقلوا الاوامر
15 المجموعه ديالهم اللي هما
هنايا شنو كنكتشف ان كاين واحد تنظيم كاين
واحد الاستراتيجيه داخل اللعبه
درنا واحد المجموعه ديال الحروب من موراه
الطريقه ديال التنظيم
وصلت لواحد المجموعه ديال المهام متقدمه
وصلت لهدف اللي بغيت ولقيت ان الحاجه اللي
خلاتني ندوز من المرحله الاولى المرحله
الثانيه هي الدافع انني نتطور انني نكتسب
مهارات جديده داخل هذيك اللعبه هادشي كامل
اللي مريت به داخل هذه اللعبه هذه اكتشف
من بعد انه عنده واحد الاسم هاد الاسم هذا
هو
مهارات ناعمه اولا
المهارات نعيمه كاين بزاف ديال الشركات
اللي كيقلبوا عليها
كاين بزاف ديال التكوينات
اللي ممكن اننا نشاركو فيها باش نتعلمو
هاد المهارات الناعمه
في الختام الحاجه اللي بغيت نبارطاجيها
معكم من هاد التجربه هو ان منين كنكونو
كنلعبو لعبه
ولكن ممكن اننا نتعلم واحد المجموعه ديال
المهارات كمهارات الابداع اللي كيستعملوا
مجموعه ديال المدارس
والمنظمات التعليميه لعبه ماين كرافت باش
انهم يعلموها الاطفال كاين لعبه اللي هي
لعبه اولا لعبه ديال الفريق خمس لاعبين ضد
فريق ديال خمس لاعبين اللي كيتحاربوا من
اجل القيام واحد المجموعه المهمات واللي
استعملوها مجموعه ديال الشركات في
التوظيفات ديالهم بالنسبه للموظفين الجدد
[تصفيق]